[Musique]
nous sommes le 24 janvier 2017 bonsoir
bienvenue pour cette édition du 7 8 les
invités émission dédiée à celles et ceux
qui font l'actualité dans le département
invités de ce soir justement pierre
cojan c'est le président de la
fédération française du bâtiment dans
les yvelines
il vient évoquer les enjeux de cette
année une embellie perspective
perceptible pardon mais depuis 2008 7000
postes ont disparu dans le département
et puis yves guillaume c'est le tout
nouveau président des jeunes démocrates
des yvelines nous dresserons son
portrait nous dira aussi comment il
compte impliqué sa formation dans les
prochaines campagnes électorales
bonsoir à tous les deux et bienvenue en
plateau pierre cojan on va commencer par
évoquer cette situation dans le bâtiment
est ce que la 2017 sera l'année de la
relance est ce que c'est une belle année
qui s'annonce dans le chou est fortement
on a eu une année 2010 est qui sait où
une embellie dans la construction neuve
logements neufs c'est une chose au
niveau des petits travaux entretien
particulier c'est très fébrile sachant
que nous 85 % ceux des entreprises du
monde disent donc que pour eux c'est
assez dur et les marchés publics
pour l'instant ces atomes ça bouge pas
donc on espère quand même un gros gâteau
avec les démarches et 9 sont espère que
de petites entreprises vont suivre puis
prendre le chemin en marche
je donnais ce chiffre tout à l'heure que
vous nous avez communiqué d'ailleurs
depuis 2008 la perte de 7000 salariés
dans les six et demi sachant qu'il a
transmis dans le bâtiment c'est à dire
que ça fait 20 % 2
de perdre depuis 2008 il ya un
ralentissement ou au contraire un
accélération ça s'est fait sur les
années alors là pour l'instant ça freine
un petit peu parce que vous rouliez
roland mais c'est que les gens les
entreprises débauchent ont beaucoup
débauché et ça c'est sous les yeux la
france entière c'est 115 milles qu'est
ce qui explique aujourd'hui cette
situation c'est quoi ces législations
dans un bouchon à la glaciation ses fils
de la fiscalité
les gens savent plus je pense qu'il ya
encore des marchés privés
mais les gens n'avaient 6 puis savent
pas quelle sauce ils seront mangés
demandons qu ils prennent pas de
décisions est simple c'est un peu de
c'est un peu dommage vous êtes inquiets
ou plutôt optimistes font du reste
optimiste et vous allez me dire mais les
discussions n'étaient pas au petit s'il
serait pas on à la fédération ce domaine
beaucoup on y croit un petit peu il ya
un petit relancer le logement match mais
c'est vrai que c'est très dur et on en a
actuellement le souci aussi des
entrepreneurs qui ont du mal à prendre
des décisions parce que demain embauché
demain mais aujourd'hui mais demain ça
sera comment donc c'est pas facile
et puis on a aussi nos entreprises
extérieures et des travailleurs détachés
qui vient chez nous qui kipré qui a par
rapport à nos cpu 30 points d'écart
alors c'est vrai qu'après dans des
démarches çà çà çà casse l'envi de de
construire 2
ton d'entreprendre ça veut dire qu'il
faut revenir à plus de protectionnisme
aussi c'est un petit peu le moc et oui
on vient se dit souvent et si oui je
pense aussi à la mode tout de suite oui
c'est une protectionnistes et surveiller
un petit peu ce qui se fait autour parce
que ces entreprises d'assaut non on nous
donne de décharge plus en plus forte des
on a on a le la pénibilité tu lesquels
l'on se bat depuis des années
j'espère bien qu'ils vont prendre une
décision bon sens or ajoute du poids
celle de l'entrepreneur de neu neu neu
leur envie d'avoir envie
il ya deux élections importantes 1
présidentielles législatives et vous
avez l'intention on imagine de peser
dans ce débat les candidats aux
primaires vous les avez interpellé par
extrapoler les candidats aux primaires
et là on a en a 84 opposition qu'on a on
va présenter aux législatives qu'ont
essayé de faire appliquer de 6 seulement
des mandatures prochaine c'est parmi ces
propositions justement quelles sont
celles de la soirée parce qu'on préfère
ça peut la refonte de la politique du
logement on a simplifié la vie
d'entrepreneur parce que l'autre puis si
compliqué - les gens ont envie
d'entreprendre réseau la fracture
territoriale la création logements
sociaux c'est en ile de france où il ya
de l'emploi qui selon le ser et par des
régions où il n'y a pas besoin
cessionnaire repenser la façon de bâtir
ça veut dire quoi ça justement repenser
la façon de matière ben c'est à dire que
l'on a bâti depuis des générations
les gens veulent habiter autrement dans
la construction est faite autrement on a
qu'avec les maisons bois on a le gens
vivent autrement les gens avaient
beaucoup de terrain avant maintenant ils
veulent peu de terrain mais le puits les
espaces de vie ça change sur sa de
fossiles adopté est donc aujourd'hui le
vos attentes véritablement pour cette
sélection est ce que vous avez été reçu
en tout cas ce que vous attendent sont
aujourd'hui ah bon c'est 10 mai le monde
s'écoute avec l'homme
les propositions que vous voyez fleurir
parmi les candidats à la primaire et
puis aujourd'hui des candidats qui sont
déclarés qui ne passe pas par la case
primaire ou qui ont déjà terminé avec
les primaires vous avez le sentiment
d'avoir été entendu il ya des choses qui
vont déjà beaucoup je pense pour je
pense qu'on a bien entendu
de là à ce que soient satisfaits on voit
si on ne se bat pas on est là pour ça
moi je je je
j'y crois ce que la france c'est un beau
pays on est on est des entrepreneurs il
n'y a pas de raison que ça c'est assez
redémarre paul on a tendance à attendre
que ça redémarre mais je pense qu'il
faut ça démarre à pas comment il faut
s'adapter au marché
mais c'est de plus en plus compliqué on
n'est pas souvent entendu elle n'est pas
souvent aidés je pense qu'il faut donner
envie aux gens d'entreprises
notre souhait pour 2010 est papa 2017 on
a en a on a les élections qui ont qui
vont être là on espère qu'il ya un
nouveau président qui veut être
entreprenant pour la france et puis pour
nous a par la même occasion bon souvent
normand aux élections c'est souvent un
frein dans les prises de décision des
clients
ses tâtonnements et aimant bien bas que
maintenant se poiler plus bas j'espère
que c'est plus que remonté le souhaite
on parle de politique à présent je vous
propose de rester en plateau avec nous
on va parler politique à venir de la
politique aussi avec vous donc re
bonsoir vous avez 23 ans vous êtes des
clayes-sous-bois étudiants en master 2
de droit ressources humaines et de
protection sociale c'est à l'université
versailles saint quentin en yvelines
et donc depuis peu à la tête des jeunes
démocrates dans le département avec cet
objectif qui vous a plus ou moins était
déjà fixé par votre aîné c'est bruno
millièmes le président du modem dans le
département conseil régional pour lui
aujourd'hui
ces formations jeunes doivent permettre
de dynamiser un petit peu l'électorat et
de faire face aussi à l'abstention
absolument absolument parce que nous les
jeunes on a un petit peu ce sentiment de
pas forcément être entendu aujourd'hui
il ya beaucoup de beaucoup de gens de
mon âge qui désertent un petit peu débat
public qui déserte la politique et ça se
traduit dans les urnes par
l'abstentionnisme
effectivement et l'objectif je pense
majeur de cette élection présidentielle
qui arrive et pour les suivantes
également pour les législatives c'est de
faire revenir les jeunes dans les
bureaux de vote de leur donner envie de
s'exprimer pour un candidat quel qu'il
soit mais déjà de leur donner l'envié de
voter
le problème c'est que pour que ces
jeunes l envie de voter il faut qu'on il
faut que les gens qui qui qui nous
représente leur donne cette envie est
quelque part qui montre un petit peu
l'exemple parce que finalement la
responsabilité première aujourd'hui elle
pèse sur les épaules de nos dirigeants
la prof d'arts particulièrement à votre
situation pourquoi le modem qu'est ce
qui vous a poussé en tant que jeunes
militants jeunes impliqués en politique
à choisir cette formation politique
alors déjà c'est un parti que je suis
depuis depuis déjà longtemps depuis
notamment depuis 2007
bon j'étais déjà jeune à l'époque donc
je vais m'engager pas je m'engageais pas
réellement j'ai suivi attentivement la
campagne de 2012 et puis deux puis voilà
c'était un petit peu je suivais ça de
plus ou moins loin mais j'avais pas
encore cette envie de m'engager
personnellement
et puis voilà j'ai sauté le pas l'année
dernière en disant que voilà la france
était dans un pays dans un état où
il était nécessaire d'agir et donc j'ai
décidé assez naturellement de m'engager
pour le modem et puis j'ai eu cette
opportunité qui s'est présentée de
prendre la présidence de la fédération
des jeunes des yvelines donc c'est une
fierté pour moi
aujourd'hui le modem qui est en pleine
discussion plus ou moins officieusement
avec les républicains on va pas revenir
sur tout autre sur tout l'historique
entre alain juppé françois fillon mais
aujourd'hui pour vous en tant que
représentant des jeunes démocrates est
ce que françois fillon c'est votre
candidat alors très sincèrement voilà
discussions ont eu lieu effectivement
avec françois fillon et françois bayrou
là l'hypothèse françois fillon semble
clairement s'éloigner aujourd'hui on ne
voit de toute manière c'est relayé par
les médias et puis voilà il reste sur
une ligne assez assez durs assez
strictes me retrouvais pas en tout cas
vous entendez en militant dans cette si
vous voulez en tant que jeune on a du
mal à se reconnaître dans le discours de
françois fillon
pourquoi alors je veux pas parler au nom
de tous les jeunes mais en tout cas pour
les jeunes du modem c'est quand même mon
programme qui est dur c'est un programme
qui parlent pas à la jeunesse on nous
parle de de protectionnisme à outrance
de 2,2 de moins d'europe de moins de
sécurité sociale etc
c'est des sujets qui sont chères aux
jeunes et on décrit en et nous dépeint
un portrait de du pays qui est quand
même assez dramatique donc ok la france
et pas forcément dans le meilleur état
dans l'état le meilleur où elle pourrait
être mais quand même et soyons un petit
peu optimiste pour la suite est
clairement françois fillon aujourd'hui
n'incarne pas vraiment cette cet
optimisme qu'on recherche
ça veut dire que françois bayrou doit se
présenter ou à l'ordre se rallier avec
un derrière un autre candidat emmanuel
macron par exemple passer effectivement
une hypothèse il ya trois hypothèses de
toute manière qu'ils sont simples
françois fillon emmanuel macron ou une
candidature de françois bayrou bon
emmanuel macron il à cet intérêt de
d'apporter une certaine fraîcheur aussi
en politique c'est quelqu'un qu'on a
qu'on voit pas depuis très longtemps il
rappelle un petit peu d'ailleurs à ce
niveau là françois bayrou en 2007
donc c'est une hypothèse qui est
crédible après il faut qu'ils aient un
programme et qu'on se retrouve dans ce
programme pour l'instant c'est encore
assez flou donc voilà j'imagine que
françois bayrou attend un petit peu de
savoir quelles sont les vraies ambitions
des manuels mâcon dans son programme en
attendant il va sortir un livre le 1er
février dans lequel il va faire un
certain nombre
propositions qui émanent d'ailleurs
directement des fédérations des
différents départements en france dont
le modem 78 enfin face à un certain
nombre de propositions qui seront
reprises dans le livre de françois
bayrou
donc voilà on il a en gros sauts modo
jusqu'au 15 février pour se décider et
puis en fonction effectivement de ce qui
va se passer dans les semaines qui
viennent je pense qu'il prendra sa
décision pour la suite de cet entretien
j'aimerais aussi qu'on comprenne
à quoi sert concrètement une célébration
d'une quel va être votre rôle pendant la
campagne quelle relation vous entretenez
aussi avec vos aînés le modem alors la
fédération de jeunes déjà elle sert à
rassembler un petit peu les jeunes qui
comme on l'a dit tout à l'heure déserte
clairement l'espace public aujourd'hui
en fin du mois le débat politique
donc déjà le le vrai le vrai enjeu c'est
de ramener un petit peu les jeunes en
politique mais pas juste pour faire de
la politique politicienne pour leur
donner envie de partager des idées de
débattre et c est de vouloir s'investir
donc ça c'est le premier point c'est de
ramener des jeunes ensuite les jeunes
dont je fais partie dans le 78 ça va
être d'être un peu un appui aussi à la
fédération est né soit pour les
prochaines échéances électorales donc
les présidentielles et même les
législatives on a un certain nombre de
candidats qui sont pris investi dans les
yvelines donc de leur apporter un
soutien humain et qui voit là matériel
logistique tout ce qu'on veut et aussi
d'apporter des idées des idées nouvelles
qui sont qui sont pas forcément sur la
table aujourd'hui chez les aînés donc
voilà c'est tjrs batterie l'ajustement
les lits des farl des majeurs que vous
attendez aujourd'hui de la part des
politiques
qu'est-ce qu'ils doivent mettre sur la
table concrètement pour intéresser les
plus jeunes il ya pas c'est une europe
nouvelle et finissent leur ans que c'est
un vrai un vrai sujet qui qui qui qui
est importante pour les jeunes parce que
c'est un petit peu notre monde de demain
quelque part et on nous parle on parlait
de françois fillon tout à l'heure qui
parle de d'une europe un peu plus
refermée sur elle-même voilà moi je
pense qu'au contraire il faut une europe
qui soit certes forte mais qui soit
ouverte et qui je pense que les sujets
de société intéresse beaucoup beaucoup
les jeunes de mon âge et c'est des
sujets sur lesquels il est important de
débattre aujourd'hui on a tendance un
petit peu trop à parler de voile à de
sécurité de laïcité etc
bon c'est bien il faut le faire mais
apportons un petit peu d'optimisme dans
le débat public et
n'ont pas peur de parler de sujets de
société que plein de jeunes comme moi
ont envie de envie de discuter en tant
que jeunes impliqués en politique ce
sera ma dernière question
brrr exit l'élection de donald trump
sont des choses qui vous inquiète qui
vous font peur oui absolument
moity voici votre engagement oui tout à
fait moi je suis un européen convaincu
donc quand je vois que quand je vois que
le royaume uni décide de sortir de
l'europe bombe à part de l'union
européenne je peux que m'en inquiéter
puis l'élection donald trump qu'on a
qu'à voir depuis moins d'une semaine
déjà les premières mesures qui ont été
prises ça ça incite pas là à l'optimisme
donc oui non peut plus sont inquiétés en
tant qu'européens c'est sûr merci d'être
venu sur notre très tôt pour réagir donc
après votre élection à la tête des
jeunes démocrates du département merci
également pierre cojan d'être venu nous
livrer quelques perspectives pour 2010
est pour la fédération du bâtiment dans
les yvelines
elle c'est la fin de cette édition du 7
8 les invités on se retrouve demain aux
horaires habituels très belle soirée
[Musique]